assistant to former President Bush
George weed wrote a memo on the lives of
presidential children next on public
lives he discusses his report and its
effect on george w bush and the new book
all the president's children it's 45
minutes
good evening Porter's customers I
importers are very pleased to welcome
this evening author Doug Wead as he
discusses all the president's children
triumph and tragedy in the lives of
America's first families an entertaining
authoritative account revealing the
public failures and personal triumphs of
the extraordinary offspring of the
nation's chief executives featuring
short biographies of living presidential
children and a chronological list of all
President children this book is both an
entertaining lesson on our nation's
history and a fascinating look at the
current administration Doug Wead was the
special assistant to President HW Bush
and he has also served as a prominent
corporate and motivational speaker in
fact he was just speaking in India last
week to 30,000 people which I thought
was very impressive since 1982 weed has
served as chairman of the annual
Washington charity dinner and was the
co-founder of Mercy Corps International
in 1979 Doug Wead currently resides in
Washington DC
mr. bead will discuss his book for about
twenty to twenty-five minutes and then
take questions from the audience so
please join me in welcoming this evening
mr. Douglas weed thanks very much thanks
Darrell that's a pretty pretty great
bookstore been hearing about it and I I
came down earlier today to look it over
a little bit I'll tell you how I got
started on this project I was working
for bush senior but my boss was Bush jr.
actually George W Bush but we called him
jr. sometimes then and sometimes he
called himself jr. later writers I
noticed will often correct people who
say George Bush jr. but I
would sit in his office many a time when
he would get on the phone and he would
say to some stubborn secretary on the
other end tell him George Bush jr. is
calling so he was George Bush jr. when
he wanted to be but he was George W to
us and he was my immediate boss and we
of his dad had won the election so he
was now president-elect we were sitting
in his office talking about who's gonna
go to transition who's gonna go to
inaugural who's gonna go into the White
House and who isn't and as we were
sitting there chatting at a certain
moment he sighed and he said well now
what's gonna happen to me which was
surprised to me he it was a rare moment
for him he didn't talk or think a lot
about himself and I hadn't either but I
had written thousands of pages for his
pop and so I immediately suggested well
you want me to write a book yeah be good
it ended up a book you want me to write
a memo on presidential kids and he said
sure
so when you're in a political campaign
like that and it's over whether you win
or lose there's a depression that sets
in because you're just going full blast
and it's like a train you hit the wall
bang it's over it's done so I had a
staff of eager young people who were
ready to go there was nothing to do they
were waiting for transition to kick in
so I gathered him around and and we said
I said to him hey we got 30 days let's
put together a memo for George W on
presidential kids what happens to them
and so we hit the library Congress flush
with the victory of a president-elect we
even contacted some presidential
children of former presidents and put
together a 44 page memo in about 30 days
it was fascinating I mean there was
everything romance illicit love murder I
I was very surprised by how ignorant I
was of presidential children and I
thought of myself as a as a amateur
historian I loved history I would
shocked at the stories I was shocked at
the impact the presidential children
have on history I mean it makes sense
our children impact our lives and our
careers so it makes sense but I had
never seen it
Eliza Monroe comes to mind she was
president Monroe Monroe's daughter and
he had another daughter who was getting
married the younger daughter Maria and
Eliza was running the White House the
mother was ill by the way that's a
common theme there are all these books
you'll find a lot of books in this
bookstore about first lady's and many of
those first lady's especially in early
American history gave birth to so many
children that by the time their husband
was elected president their bodies were
worn out and it was a daughter that ran
the White House the histories of the
first lady but there's a couple first
ladies who never entered Washington I
guess you know about some of those not
I'll tell you but anyway some very
insightful stories and the one of the
Monroe daughter is that Eliza had gone
to a school in France graduated from
that school came to the United States
and really felt more Continental and she
did American and was a bit offended by
the frontier culture of America and so
she tried to impose on the White House
the refinement that she'd picked up in
France and in the process I guess this
had this happens and shouldn't be
surprised in the process offended of all
people the the the French and Spanish
and English diplomats it was the
Europeans who didn't like her version of
what European society should be like and
so this feud developed between the
Monroe daughter and the diplomatic corps
in Washington DC and so when Maria had a
wedding iliza her older sister stepped
in took it over and refused to let any
of the diplomats come to the wedding
well this was the first big wedding in
American history this was the first time
a presidential daughter was going to get
married and of course the tradition the
tradition in Europe marriages were state
events
were the mergers of kingdoms they were
they were hotly debated before they took
place and after they took place and so
the Europeans were used to having big
weddings but they were not used to being
shut out and so there was a big argument
about it it poisoned poisoned cabinet
meetings and I tell you that whole story
to say that when James Monroe and John
Quincy Adams his Secretary of State sat
down to forge the Monroe Doctrine the
Monroe family was pretty bitter towards
many of those European kingdoms anyway
and Ally sahat her little role to play
in the Monroe Doctrine and to strengthen
the spine of her father who who made it
his policy that no one should interfere
from in the Western Hemisphere that was
a threat to the United States but my
first reaction in doing that study was
one of fear because I like GW I was
working for him and I started on the
study for purposes of finding out what
it was going to be like for him and what
I noticed is and in these 15 years of
researching this subject what has only
been confirmed is that if a firstborn
son is named after the father or if he's
brought in the White House to work for
the father which happened in several
occasions or he is in some other way
positioned as the heir apparent they die
we all die but they die young and John
Adams the second for example died an
alcoholic at thirty-one William Henry
Harrison jr. died an alcoholic at 35
Andrew Johnson jr. died at 26 Calvin
Coolidge jr. died at 16 he was injured
on the White House tennis courts he
developed a blister and turned to
septicemia and blood poisoning and he
died Andrew Jackson jr. was killed in a
hunting accident died of lockjaw after a
hunting accident I could go on and on
and on it just it's uncanny there's a
few there's a few juniors that survived
a good example
is Teddy Roosevelt jr. he lived to be 54
that's old for an heir apparent but he
tried I mean he was so reckless that
Teddy Roosevelt once told his wife that
if he survives to adulthood it'll be a
miracle and I've got a picture in the
book all the president's children that
shows TR jr. jumping the fence on a
horse with T are watching on he's very
reckless in World War 1 TR jr. was
wounded twice in World War 2 he was in
the heat of battle he was the first in
the landings in North Africa and you
know maneuv studied a lot of World War
two the North Africa landings seemed
pretty tame I mean it seems like they
came up to the doct and they all walked
off but TR jr. killed somebody on the
beach he shot a German in the head in
hand-to-hand combat on the beach he was
the first to land and Sicily with the
first wave in Sicily and it course he
was a general by that time he was in the
first wave that landed on d-day and he
was the only general to land with his
troops in the first day and the first
wave and the d-day invasion in fact in
the movie the longest day Henry Fonda
plays TR junior and he stands out there
on the beach with his cane he's hobbling
around and these bullets are whizzing by
him general Abrams was asked at one
point what was the bravest act he'd ever
seen in his life and he said it was it
was TR jr. the story of TR Junior's
standing out on that beach in Normandy
and so he stood there a man in his 50s
with his cane directing the young people
who were landing on the beaches of
Normandy where to go and where the
German machine-gun nests were and what
to avoid with bullets whizzing all
around him so he tried but he died of a
heart attack at 50 for a few months
after Normandy and was awarded the Medal
of Honor so I was disturbed by what I
found higher than average rates of
divorce higher than average rates of
alcoholism higher than average rates of
premature death and my boss was named
after his father too
so I presented this study to him rather
timidly because I knew him and I know
that you know he can't be stampeded into
anything and he doesn't he's understated
and as his pop and the whole family is
so I just kind of gave it without
comment and he looked through it a
little bit and the only comment he had
at one point there was a very eerie
mirror between the George Bush family
Senior and the Franklin D Roosevelt
family in that each had four boys and a
daughter and each had a sixth child that
died in early one of the Roosevelt's
went west and so did one of the bushes
one of the Roosevelt's went to Florida
and was elected to office and one of the
bushes had gone to Florida and was
Secretary of Commerce at the time and
FDR jr. went home to New York the home
state to run for governor it was no
secret that GW was thinking about that
so he asked me was the only question he
asked about the study he said well what
happened to FDR jr. I said he lost and I
said in fact no presidential son has
ever been elected governor and he
groaned and that was his only reaction
and then it went into file 13 and for 15
years I've been clipping and pasting and
correcting my 44 page memo which has
become a 600 page memo but when John F
Kennedy jr. disappeared over the
Atlantic I had chills go down my spine
because I thought this is not a
coincidence of history this has happened
over and over and over again there is
stress on these young people from the
time they're little children people come
up to them and say well when are you
gonna run for president if they bear the
name Andrew Jackson jr. Andrew Johnson
jr. Calvin Coolidge jr. if they bear the
name it it's killer and I had someone
the other day talking to me about this
very same thing they said well George W
Bush escaped all that and he didn't he
had a drinking problem he was headed
with all the confidence of a sleepwalker
write down this same path that other
juniors had gone and he he took charge
in his life and made a decision and and
and changed turned it around but he was
headed that way so in this study there
was good - there were some fabulous
stories and say one last thing about JFK
jr. just forget off him Jackie Kennedy
is one of the best of the moms when you
read this book
you're gonna conclude boy she did a lots
of things right and when you when most
of you are familiar with her childhood
and you know some of the trauma she
experienced as a child which makes it
all the more admirable she was a great
mom and it's no accident that John and
Carolyn or as classy as they were and as
we expected them to be but before she
died she could not resist and Jackie
Kennedy's last note to her son before
her death was you especially have a
place in history and of course five
years later he was gone so there is
tremendous stress on these young people
to live up to the image of the father if
you're not named after the father you
might slip away for example I found one
of the children of living children of a
president living on an island at work
the local newspaper
we called them first said we've here
this guy they said oh here he lives here
too but but we we don't know so I
thought well the local editors don't
know and it's an island they ought to
know
turns out he lived there eight years I
called his place of work and said is the
president's son and I named him there
they said well he's here but he's not
the president's son I said well may I
speak to him I spoke to him and it was
the president's son so here's a former
president's son working for eight years
with people that don't know his dad
was the president the United States and
I write about him in my book and
recently we had had a suggestion the TV
producer one just to bring together some
presidential kids and sit him on a
roundtable and discuss what life in the
bubbles like so I phoned the this kid
back thinking I'd built a relationship
with him and maybe he'd come off his
island and be a part of a TV show and
they said he's gone left no forwarding
address so I guess I ruined his life
I didn't mean to maybe maybe there was
some other reason maybe it was
coincidental but anyway he was there
eight years and nobody knew who he was
and so some presidential kids they can
you know maybe the Johnson kids
especially they couldn't slip slip away
but it's pretty tough I mean a great
American baseball player can walk down
the street so the Shaun's Elysees and
the only body that recognizes him is
American tourists but a presidential kid
anywhere in the world the buzz is out on
the street here it comes here they come
do you know who they are and there's no
escape very quickly when I started
working on this within the first few
months of working on this book I spent
two years writing at the 15 years
collecting things very quickly from a
personal standpoint it turned from a
work of history to work of psychology
and good parenting because I brought
these lessons in these stories back to
my wife and and we we were learning this
gobbling up as much information as we
could because here are very brilliant
people presidents of the United States
making mistakes and one of the things
that we learn is good parenting is no
big secret there have been a numbers of
studies at universities and they pretty
well conclude the same thing that there
are four ingredients in good parenting
and you can't control what your kid's
going to do but the four are gentle but
firm with unconditional love and no
favorites and that's basically it and
there were some great parents the
Garfield's are great parents every one
of their kids are successful
Ruth referred to Behe's and Lucy Hayes
were great parents every one of their
kids is successful in different areas
different vocations and every one of
them turns out just great George and
Barbara Bush are very successful parents
in fact i sat down with GW and I have a
tape recording of an interview with him
when I said what's your parenting the
parenting philosophy of your mom and pop
and he laid out this University of
Minnesota study point-by-point and the
study was published two years later so I
know that he hadn't read it but either
by accident or design or luck or the the
Bush's did a good job with their kids
what happened the recent election
elections of two bushes to the
governorships is an extraordinary event
in American history many of us will say
well they've got name recognition and
they got money they ought to win what's
the big deal but a Stevenson ran in
Illinois and couldn't win as a governor
a Humphrey ran in Minnesota it was the
only state that Walter Mondale carried
against Ronald Reagan he should win it
he lost it to an independent a Taft ran
in Ohio and couldn't win and lost a
Kennedy was putting together his
campaign in Massachusetts and because of
some controversies and fluctuations in
the polls he backed down from a race
another Kennedy Kathleen Townsend
Kennedy Townsend ran just recently near
us in Maryland where Democrats
registered Democrats outnumber
Republicans two-to-one and lost so
whether the child's been the child of a
Republican or a Democrat and no matter
how much name recognition they had no
child of a president ever was elected
governor of a state our child of a vice
president or a presidential nominee
until two bushes ended up winning so it
is an extraordinary event historically
yes yes but he's not the son of the
president Charley Taft was the one that
ran for governor and and lost so here
are some letters from Thomas Jefferson
that I thought were fascinating
Jefferson wrote Patsy a letter
and he says and the letters in the book
he says here is a list of things you can
do to earn my love now when I read that
I thought boy I got no hope I mean
Thomas Jefferson's got to be one of the
smartest presidents we ever had and if
he can't see it what kind of dad could I
possibly be as smart as he is and TR if
there was a second most brilliant
president many would say that Teddy
Roosevelt was and Teddy Roosevelt openly
favored TR jr. and he wrote him letters
telling him so so I quickly from a
personal standpoint I did the book it
was history but from a personal
standpoint I I soaked up as much
information I could as how to be a good
dad and my wife how to be a good mom and
what we could do what was interesting is
a lot of these kids triumph anyway when
the parent did everything wrong I think
Richard Taylor was a great example of
that Richard Taylor his dad Zachary
Taylor the president said I hardly know
my children or they know me and he
didn't have him around when he's
president United States he didn't want
his son in Washington didn't want him in
the city so I didn't share any of the
glory with him either if any child was
abandoned in their life Zachary Taylor's
son Richard Taylor was abandoned and
he's one of the greatest of the
presidential kids it becomes one of
Lee's generals and wins all these
battles he's the guy that taught
Stonewall Jackson how to teach his
troops out of March and of course we got
that movie coming out in a few days so
Bush and Adams I'll say this about that
we'll get into some questions and
answers and comments I'd like to hear
your comments about this because I'm
here to learn from you too I was
intrigued by the fact that both the bush
and Adams became president and what did
they do differently and I found very
quickly there they couldn't compare him
not only were they divided by centuries
and cultures and but their method of
child raising too was very very
different the John Quincy Adams
experience in
my opinion from a parental standpoint
was an aberration it was an accident
John Adams went to France with his 11
year old son John Quincy with him
they lived in one room together they did
not know the language they could not
trust Benjamin Franklin who was the
other American they're on the team and
they only had each other they had no
television and a father undoubtedly
shared with the son things that he would
never share in any other circumstance it
is a rare moment in time two men one
11-year old boy and another a man in his
late forties living in the same room
both future presidents of the United
States and they got nothing to see or
read or talk to but each other and they
learned the French language together and
John Adams was a bit stunned and a bit
hurt that John Quincy learned French
quicker than he did of course today we
all know why I mean if we we could even
I mean with biofeedback so they can even
show us how our brain works and why kids
learn language quicker than adults do
but John Adams was convinced that his
young son was a genius and John Quincy
gained confidence from that that he drew
on for the rest of his life because he
knew that his dad wasn't faking it that
his dad was really impressed with him
and John Quincy went on to a great
career when he was 14 years old it was a
pretty rare thing to have someone that
we could trust in the American
government who could actually speak
French which of course was the
diplomatic language so we needed him and
he was immediately assigned to
allegation and very quickly as a young
man he became an ambassador here's
career was on his way as an old man John
Quincy became intrigued with the whole
idea of genius and he wrote a number of
essays about what is genius and he came
to the conclusion that genius was just
focusing on a particular thing and I
found it interesting because it seemed
to me that his genius betrayed him at
the end he couldn't solve a lot of the
problems he wanted to solve even in his
own family and came to the conclusion
maybe realized finally that hey
I wasn't as smart as I thought i hus but
but whatever it was it took him to the
top and the reason I say it was an
aberration is because the other brother
Charles the dad says this worked so good
with John Quincy I'm gonna go home and
do it with Charles so he comes back to
the United States and he tells Abigail
this is so fantastic and let's take
Charles back to Europe so he takes
Charles back to Europe but brings along
John Quincy can't do without John Quincy
so now they get to France and they're
they're back at this at the same court
but John Adams conclusion was it was his
Stern admonitions and super visions of
John Quincy that made him great and his
exposure to a foreign culture so when he
comes back by now John Adams knows can
speak French John Quincy can speak
French when they go out to dinner when
they go to events nobody's there to
interpret for Charles he's got to learn
on his own it doesn't work and very soon
they're separated they're going to
school John Quincy and Charles the dads
at another apartment doesn't work the
dad can't figure it out I mean Charles
dies an alcoholic at a young age John
Quincy grows up convinced that his dad's
Stern control and admonition and
strictness and exposure to a foreign
culture is what made him great he tries
it with his own kids and it doesn't work
his firstborn son commits suicide his
second son struggles and again has an
alcoholic problem dies young at the age
of 31 fact he has an interesting letter
to his second son his second son is at
Harvard and John Quincy Adams says he's
president now he's the sitting president
he says I'm not going to come to your
Harvard graduation unless you're in your
top 25 of your class so the son works
like a dog and he gets in the top 25 and
he gets to five and the dad writes him a
letter and says if you're not number one
it's not worth doing and so the father
says I'm not coming anyway and John
Adams the second is soon after expelled
from Harvard and doesn't finish it and
dies young so in my opinion and of
course I could be wrong but I'll let you
read it I don't give my opinion in the
book I just state the facts I think John
Quincy was an accident
an aberration and we've learned a lot
more about parenting one of the things
you'll notice in the appendix is a chart
the life and death of these children and
prior to the Civil War a presidential
child would die about eleven point nine
years younger than the average person
which is a remarkable statistic because
they had a higher education and they had
better nutrition and they should have
lived a lot longer than the average but
after the Civil War when we've learned
more about parenting they adapt they
they do a whole lot better anyway
I'm running out of time love to talk
about Webb Hayes he's a character that
Hollywood could not invent a dashing
multi-millionaire founds what becomes
the Union Carbide corporation risks all
his money to go to China and fight and
Wars that he has no business fighting in
becomes a soldier of fortune and African
Wars and the Crimea and all over the
world a remarkable person and then comes
home and starts what becomes the first
presidential library there is one
subject that I can't escape just because
it's so fascinating to me and I don't
know how it fits in life but it this is
just fascinating to me
many presidents and their children have
encounters with death and you know many
presidents one of the one of the
greatest experiences psychologists tell
us in life even a necessity a
psychological necessity of life is
recognition of peers and being elected
president has got to be a big one and
they psychologists also tell us that one
of the most stressful events that we can
experience as humans is the death of a
child
what stunned me is how frequently a
presidential career was triggered by the
death of a child we're talking Lincoln
we're talking Jackson we're talking
about people who don't want to come home
to their wife so instead of divorce
which often occurs when there's a death
of a child in our society in early
America where divorce was not a social
option their way out is public life
where they can be alone so Lincoln who
didn't want to go home to his wife after
the death of Eddie hit
the road and campaign for Congress and
it was his escape in fact once he says
in one of his speeches if the good
people of of Illinois decide not to send
me said I've experienced a lot worse and
then he shows this attitude that the
overcoming fear and his ability to run
for office so anyway that was a
fascination to me I'll in with this
thought all of us every one of us as
children seek the approval of our Father
or the father figure in our life through
mimicry and completion mimicry is when
you root for the Yankees because your
dad was for the Yankees completion is
when you get a college education and
you're the first one in your family to
get a college education I found in this
study that presidential children first
born particularly women and men tended
towards completion because they could
not mimic the presidency so William
Henry Harrison's son became a doctor
when he learned that his father had
wanted to be a doctor John F Kennedy jr.
became a publisher when he learned from
his father's friends that his dad had
always wanted to be a publisher TR jr.
won the Medal of Honor when he learned
that his father's greatest
disappointment in life was failing to
win the Medal of Honor Margaret Truman
our Margaret Wilson whose father
constantly complained that he didn't
have time to think he'd only been in
government two years before he was
president had no time to think had to
make all these decisions Margaret Wilson
joined an ashram in India never married
and spent her whole life in meditation
which brings us to George W Bush George
W Bush father was accused of not really
being a Texan of keeping a hotel and Bay
Shore Inn in Houston Texas and really
livin in Kennebunkport but the son is
proven that bushes are Texans and the
father's greatest disappointment the
family's greatest disappointment was a
perceived lack of integrity over read my
lips no new taxes and then lowering the
taxes George W is going to lower the
taxes whether you want it or not and
lower the taxes and lower the taxes and
he's wiping off the pages of history
read my lips no new taxes he will make
it very clear that the name Bush means
low taxes and finally
there's Saddam Hussein and it was left
undone and as many other presidential
sons before him as you and I we please
the father image in our life through
mimicry and completion and I wouldn't be
surprised if completion occurs thank you
very much
any comments anybody love to hear your
comments and ideas yes both Quincy and
Bush jr. lost the popular vote and and
Quincy Adams also lost the second term
does but is Bush afraid of that
happening losing the second time I'm
sure I don't I would say just from what
I know of him as a person he's not
afraid on a conscious level because the
but I'm sure that's part of completion
he wouldn't mind getting reelected I
mean the bush is the Bush family have
always been have always a part of them
has always said I don't need this I can
walk away from this of course they must
on some level really need it or they
wouldn't do it but I remember I was with
Neal even the first time that senior was
gonna run and Neal is saying he may not
run he was talking to mom the other day
he may not run so I think this is a way
device for them to say I don't need this
size so that they aren't hurt so bad if
if they have to walk away with it so I
doubt if GW is afraid of it but at some
level I'm sure he wants it
ah hi there thanks for your speech um I
was thinking about a question kind of
hedging in media studies because you
know with the increasing tabloid ization
of of the media I'm sure this has
affected the way that historians
approach the idea of the presidency and
you know family issues surrounding it so
now we have issues like with even
presidential families no al bush or was
a marine or paddy Reagan whichever one
came out against her you know against
Reagan prior to this period post
watergate is there you know a sense of
presidential children betraying a
rebelling from you know the the cultural
legacy of their fathers the answer that
question is no it's gone on from the
very beginning
I mean before Watergate Franklin
Roosevelt he had a son who opposed the
New Deal he had a son who opposed his
own his father's re-election he had
another son he had several of his
children worked for his father's
opponents at various times the Hearst
family and and different newspaper
chains one started a radio chain in
Texas that was similar to some of our
talk radio of today was on the opposite
end of the political spectrum from his
father and what what's going on there in
my opinion is the search for identity
because Patty Reagan could be much more
effective she's one that opposed her
father's policies when he was in power
she could have been much more effective
as the president's daughter than just
standing out on the street and shouting
her views which gave some comfort to
those who shared her views but was not
as effective because she is actually a
member of the family an example of
someone who had opposite views from
their father and was very effective was
Helen Taft Manning who favored the vote
for women and worked tirelessly to
convince her very conservative father
who had been president and was Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court that this
was a good idea
and she she did not go out on the street
corner and denounce her family or you
know find comfort with people who hated
the TAFEs she worked within the family
was very effective so I'm not
criticizing the child who who does
attack the president I'm saying that
happened frequently in history and in my
observation it usually happened not
primarily because this political issue
was as important to the child as it was
that the child is saying I am me I am
NOT you I am me and is searching for
identity because the the president's
celebrity smothers their identity to
things constantly in conflict with these
children as they are with us intimacy
and identity so on the one hand you
reach out to your mom and your dad and
you pull them close because you need
that intimacy especially before you're
married or you have any other
relationships as an adult on the other
hand with the other hand you push your
parents away because you want identity
you want to exist on your own and that's
a conflict that takes place and it is
especially troubling for presidential
children because they have no identity
Steve Ford told me one time he said when
I meet people on the street a complete
stranger we start talking he said it
says F I don't exist it's as if I'm
invisible
very quickly they're talking to my dad
they imagine that I'm gonna go home and
get on the phone and call my dad up and
tell him what this person on the street
just told me and I a says I'm invisible
he said I get the feeling I didn't even
exist so on the one hand they have to
have identity somehow they have to find
that to be healthy normal person but
they also need intimacy and so there's
that conflict
what stood out about presidential
daughters presidential daughters oh the
one thing that stood out is you know
they died younger than presidential sons
and it was because early in American
history the pressure was on for sons and
daughters to be successful in early in
American history
many women were determined successful
based on the number of children they had
so the pressure was on for these early
American daughters of presidents to have
lots of children so while the the son
was out there competing with the father
trying to prove to the Father that he's
good that he he can run for office too
that he can help his dad's political
career the daughter was just having as
many kids as she could possibly have and
they just died from childbirth
complications it was very sad for me to
see these daughters some of them are
very strong there's a chapter in here
called resilient women and some of the
women that come off so strong Patsy
Jefferson is one and Martha Johnson
Andrew Johnson's daughters unbelievable
the mother's worn out the mother's sick
invalid the dad gets elected to Congress
so he's going to go back to Washington
by himself so he takes Martha so the
daughter this little girl is his
companion in Washington while he's a
congressman she's with him all the time
he's in Congress she all her life she
helps all her life she sacrifices for
him in his career she becomes de-facto
first lady her mother's upstairs and
invalid in the White House
Martha's running it there's an
impeachment trial on they hate her
father she has to go down to the
Congress and Senate and beg for money to
to have to clean up the White House and
after the Civil War it was a mess
there's cigar stains and tobacco stains
in the corners and it just Mary Lincoln
was a recluse upstairs in her last few
months there was urine stains and the
corners of the White House it was filthy
mess Martha Johnson had to get in there
and clean it up she kept cows on the
lawn the South Lawn so they could have
milk to stay within the budget and she
set some precedence and entertainment
she's just a country girl from Tennessee
and she said some
and entertainment that are still
observed in the white house today she's
a remarkable woman she named her
children after Andrew Johnson he was not
there for the birth of any of her
children he was not there for her own
wedding because he was so important he
always gave to him it was always a
one-way street and but she was you know
the one who gives is the one who's
strong and when you read this story by
the time you get to the end you conclude
she is a remarkable woman the president
mm-hmm he has some good moments and bad
but she is a remarkable woman there's
some sad stories of women I can't resist
telling you this one because this one is
so wistful and knocks Taylor is a very
beautiful girl and when she is young
her father Zachary Taylor is assigned to
the Mississippi Delta where he builds a
building a dam they're hit by bilious
fever which which was a doctor's term
for a catch-all we think it's malaria
one of the children dies then the second
child dies all of them have this fever
Knox is the third but she survives
barely but she had the fever she almost
died she grows up to be a beauty and now
Zachary Taylor the Taylor's stay out of
the Mississippi Delta now they're living
in Kentucky and there's this young
gentleman on Zachary Taylor's staff by
the name of Jefferson Davis and he's
kind of a cantankerous guy and he soon
has arguments with the commander Zachary
Taylor and Zachary Taylor can't stand
him so sure enough Knox Taylor his
daughter falls in love with Jefferson
Davis and Taylor says not over my dead
body so they run off and they get
married they lope and Jefferson Davis
takes his bride to the Mississippi Delta
where he lives on their honeymoon and
she writes a letter home to her mother
and says I know you're afraid of this
region but the air is fine they thought
you caught malaria are bilious fever
from the air the air is fine and I feel
very good the next day she came down
with a fever and so did Jefferson Davis
and on their honeymoon they suffered
with a high fever it lasted three months
Jefferson Davis survived became the
president of the Confederate States of
America one day knocks Taylor died in
the Mississippi Delta that almost took
her as a child that came back in and
took her as a newlywed so that's it I
don't know what that proves but it was
to me a very sad and romantic tale of
these presidential children parallel in
the way John Quinn John Adams you know
pulled his son John Quincy Adams to him
and into also the way George Bush Senior
brought his song along to followed in in
the leadership footsteps I think there's
this parallel I think the parallel is in
both cases either through accident or
design the father gave some time to the
child I can't tell you how many times
when I would read these letters of
presidents are buried in the library
Connor so you can go through them and
you can really get all Abraham Lincoln
man you really get a picture of a guy
with the letters he writes to a son or
doesn't write to his sons and I kept
finding myself screaming at these pages
because the first lady in the president
would be saying like let's take for
example one of Andrew Johnson's children
they were planning to send this young
man to Liberia because they wanted him
to have a foreign experience and because
they felt that they could keep him away
from alcohol and another example is one
of the Roosevelts Kermit Roosevelt the
wife was pleading to have him stationed
in Alaska in a remote base for that
purpose to help him dry out William
Henry Harrison had a son that he was
trying to dry out they were getting him
posted way out in the West where they
would have some control over and what I
and my wife was helping me study this
what we would keep saying to each other
is they need you they need you and
that's what John Quincy had when he was
in France he had John Adams he had his
dad and it made all the difference and
to an extent at various times the Bush's
have had him although I remind you
that there are examples of presidential
sons who were abandoned their whole life
and there turned out fabulous and
Winston Churchill is certainly a
definition of an abandoned child and he
turned out great
so every rule was broken but there were
certainly some trends
chelsey all the presidential children
that I interviewed and we talked to a
lot of them including got at least
little hello with Warren G Harding's
daughter born out of wedlock who's still
alive by the way and living in a remote
region of the world but almost all of
them applauded Chelsea and felt she was
remarkable because she had no siblings
to talk to and it wasn't that that that
the presidential children told us they
couldn't trust their parents the
President and First Lady but there were
things that the President and First Lady
couldn't understand and when the
presidential children had sibling they
could they could talk to each other and
Chelsea had no siblings and the other
thing that they were they felt was
remarkable with Chelsea is we think that
a presidential child can just go to the
room and lock the door and the media
will pass over that you can be a Garbo
like child as what they said of love
Chelsea but it isn't true the press is
so invasive of a presidential child that
the presidential child has to be
proactive to stay out of the media they
had there's times they have to pick up
the phone or have the parent pick up the
phone and call a producer and say please
please lay off and Chelsea was able to
walk through those minefields and it
speaks very well of President mrs.
Clinton one of the things that the
Clintons were criticized for was a prep
session with Chelsea where they
criticized her heavily criticized each
other heavily to give her an example of
what the campaign was gonna be like and
supposedly Chelsea fled in tears but
though the Clintons were criticized for
this this is exactly what presidential
parents should be doing with their
children and it was it's very clear in
these stories that when a presidential
child was trusted by the President and
First Lady and brought in to the process
they they did much better there there
was less fear and less confusion less
mistakes and more confidence thank you
Darrell this has been an enlightening
evening for me and a great privilege
thank you very much
[Applause]
I'd like to thank Doug Wead for being
here today again the book is all the
president's children and the books are
available up here and if you have any
additional questions or would like to
get your book sign you can come on up
thank you very much for those customers
for coming tonight Doug Wead is
co-founder of Mercy Corps a global food
and medicine distribution group all the
president's children premieres this
weekend at number 13 on the New York
Times bestseller list
it's published by atria books a division
of Simon & Schuster visit Simon Says
dot-com for more information next week
on